[Music]  but what is this place what's your name  honey  I'm Joe I teach middle school band how'd  it go for today started out as the best  day of my life  back here tonight first shows at 7:00  you know what this gonna say Joe Gardner  I got the gig  must have been certain for you  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]  huh no it's the great before this is  where new Souls get their personalities  quirks and interest before they go to  earth  may 28th and I don't want anything to do  with it you're missing out on the joys  of life like pizza I can't smell we  can't we can't taste either all that  stuff is in your body no smell no taste  or touch see okay Wow  is all this living really worth dying  for  you're so mine can you help me get back  no  [Music]  hmm they sweet what does it 151,000  Saul's going to the great beyond every  day you know I can't easily single one  of them  the counts off  [Music]